it's the easter weekend april 2020
and this sheffield care home is crippled
by covid
how are you feeling our cameras
documented what happened here
staff didn't have the proper protective
equipment or ppe
and residents were dying of covid
i want to get out of this place you mean
guidance from public health england to
ministers failed to recognize the risk
posed to elderly residents by
non-symptomatic spread of the virus
a sky news investigation at the time
revealed that supplies of ppe were being
diverted to the nhs away from care homes
and worse elderly patients were being
discharged into homes without a covered
test
we now know that the policy guidance
documents released in march and april
were unlawful and failed to protect
elderly residents
it's something we asked the health
secretary about at the time
you knew and your department knew that
this was a high risk area
you gave you've issued guidance
to care homes repeatedly over the last
few months i wonder if you will take
this opportunity to apologize to those
families of loved ones who died in care
homes because
the government didn't properly protect
them that's
the thing is nick i think that's
i think that's unreasonable as a
question actually
but now the high court has ruled that
the government broke the law
care homeowner nicola richards lost 28
residents to covid
the government told us all the way
through the pandemic that put a
protective ring around us that's just
lies ultimately it never happened
it i think what they've done the lies is
absolutely unforgivable they should
apologize to every single family member
who's lost loved ones they should hang
the red and shame basically
a spokesperson for matt hancock said
this court case comprehensively clears
ministers of any wrongdoing and finds mr
hancock acted responsibly on all counts
the court also found that public health
england failed to tell ministers what
they knew about asymptomatic
transmission mr hancock has frequently
stated how he wished this had been
brought to his attention earlier
lindsay allison's father-in-law john
died from covid in a care home after
being discharged from hospital without a
test
absolutely disgusted i don't know why
it's taken two years
for somebody to decide that the
government have broken the law
when i've been saying this from the
start we've known from the start they
sent the elderly into care homes without
testing them first
allowing my father-in-law and many
others like him to pass away
the lasting and painful legacy for many
families is that they will never know if
the death of their loved one in a care
home could have been prevented nick
martin sky news sheffield